حسنًا ، كنا في قاعدة رامشتاين الجوية
بالأمس ورأينا بعضًا من تلك
الرحلات الجوية القليلة القادمة في منطقة الوصول
، وهو مزيج من المشاعر التي يشعر بها الناس
بالتعب ولكنهم يشعرون بالارتياح أيضًا ، ولكن
بالنسبة لعائلة معينة ، كانت هناك بعض
الأخبار الجيدة جدًا
وهي صورة  الأمل وسط الفوضى ، أصبحت
طفلة ولدت في خليج البضائع التابع
لسلاح الجو الأمريكي C-17 تحمل من تم إجلاؤهم من السلاح أثناء
هبوط الطائرة في قاعدة رامشتاين الجوية التي
هرعت إليها المجموعة الطبية رقم 86
لتسليم
قاعدتها الجوية رونشتاين بأمان في
ألمانيا.  تم تصوير أحدث مركز لرحلات الإجلاء
من أفغانستان CNN حيث
وصلت بعض الرحلات الأولى
تم إجلاء أكثر من 6000
رحلة هنا مع هبوط 17 رحلة في غضون 24 ساعة
يقول مسؤولو القاعدة الجوية والمزيد قادم إلى
هنا ، هناك طعام ومأوى أساسي آمن.
إنه مجرد إجراء مؤقت
لا يعرف الكثير هنا إلى أين
سيذهبون بعد ذلك أو كيف سيذهبون ،
ولكن في الوقت الحالي هناك
راحة وسبب للاحتفال بحياة جديدة
، تبلغ السعة في القاعدة الجوية
7500 و e  على الرغم من عدم
وصول الرحلات الجوية مساء الأحد ، فمن
المتوقع أن تستمر صباح يوم الاثنين ، لذا
فهي تمتلئ بسرعة ولا يزال من غير
الواضح إلى أين سيذهب الأشخاص الذين تم إجلاؤهم إلى
Atika shubert CNN التالية في قاعدة رامشتاين الجوية
في ألمانيا